leïla et pierre ont décidé de continuer
leur combat
ces deux enseignants du collège lucie
aubrac de givors dans le rhône vont
poursuivre leur grève de la faim entamée
le 25 janvier une série de trois
agressions graves en quatre jours contre
plusieurs de leurs collègues de travail
sont à l'origine de cette action
un ultime cri d'alarmé un dernier
recours pour ces deux professeurs
mobilisés depuis plus de cinq ans pour
que leurs établissements obtiennent le
label réseau d'éducation prioritaire
renforcée des épisodes de violence on en
a toujours connu un mois en 25 ans j'en
ai toujours connu mais ça restait très
très très exceptionnelle et ça n'avait
jamais la proportion que ça a pris à une
quinzaine de jours mais les problèmes
étaient là avant c'est à dire que notre
mouvement il n'est pas en réaction à
cette violence c'est cette violence qui
nous a permis de nous révéler à nous
mêmes à quelques fois une situation
devenait dramatique à quel point notre
analyse depuis 5 6 ans était juste et à
quel point notre revendication depuis
cinq six ans de l'absolu m'en être
entendu et là tout de suite maintenant
une grève de la faim donc qui a alerté
le rectorat
ce dernier a publié ce jeudi un
communiqué de presse annonçant la fin de
la mobilisation des enseignants une
publication intervenue alors que
l'inspecteur de l'académie de lyon était
toujours en visite dans l'établissement
malgré l'annoncé notamment de
l'augmentation de moyens humains et une
dotation globale à ajuster des
ressources normalement accordée à un
collège ray plus leïla et pierre vont
continuer leurs actions pour nous faire
entendre c'est la seule voie qu'on ait
pu trouver et d'ailleurs malheureusement
on se rend compte que on avait fait le
bon qu'on a fait le bon choix puisque
aujourd'hui si on arrive à se faire
entendre
c'est grâce à cette grève de la faim
cette grève de la faim nous l'avons
entamée puisque depuis 2015 nous avons
besoin de moyens dans cet établissement
depuis 2015 on nous dit patienter on
nous avait dit en 2019 qu'on aurait les
moyens et puis en 2019
il ya eu un changement de
man aujourd'hui on nous dit mais
attendez encore un an et demi mais dans
un an et demi il y aura à nouveau un
changement de gouvernement
que fait-on avec nos élèves comment
pouvons nous travailler de manière
optimale avec tous ces jeunes
la méthode employée par l'académie ainsi
que ses propositions ne conviennent pas
aux deux professeurs ils ont le soutien
sans faille de leur direction et de
leurs collègues d'établissement qui se
sont tous constitués en collectif le 25
janvier dernier le collectif lucie
aubrac à d'ailleurs envoyé une lettre ce
jeudi à jean michel blanquer
ils demandent une audience au ministre
de l'éducation nationale pour discuter
du classement aurait plus de leur
collège
et ce alors que leur ministère de
tutelle a remis au budget de l'état 200
millions d'euros non dépensés